finish it all up well now it's time for  another special treat besides the the  reindeer did you know that nate does  more than just traffic and weather no of  course he's been playing the flute here  in the valley for a long long time every  once in a while he breaks it out right  here on good day las vegas as well and  so nate the question is what do you have  in store now well you could probably  imagine guys thank you so much that we  are going to be doing something holiday  related in fact we're calling this a  special holiday edition of flutie 2d  friday  [Music]  and this is a song that is near and dear  to my heart it's my all-time favorite  christmas carol you could probably  imagine it has something to do with my  last name  me  [Music]  me  [Applause]  autonom that's my last name  this is the only time of year john where  it's okay for my nose to light up that's  your flutie 2d holiday friday  very good thank you nate appreciate that